on va voir si vous coller à la moyenne
des français et on va vous faire une
interview opinion publique en bouche
oui
il ya beaucoup ya de plus en plus je
sais que je me fasse respecter merde
bien ya quinze ans c'est pas un peu la
foi c'est un peu mais toi michel
michel il t'en fous tu soutien fort à un
gbagbo c'est vrai c'est vrai bah oui
dans 69 % des couples
la femme fait le ménage comment ça se
passe mieux avec fabrice en l'occurrence
on s'est partagé les pièces de
l'appartement d'à quoi bien faire une
cuisine une chambre un salon qui fait
les chiottes
vous avez pensé mais alors dans 73% des
coupes cette fois la femme fait la
cuisine chez vous c'est comment sinon
vous fait pas manger on n'a pas le temps
arrange pas ou alors on achète tout prés
environnants
alors on ouvre une salade tout fait et
on mange comme d'accord alors
l'industrie cloud alors 50 % des femmes
fantasment sur leurs partenaires du
moment et vous ah bah oui complètement
ouais moi pendant 70 jours il est
attendu un bail que j'ai fantasmé dit je
sais pas c'est quand ils sont tombés
après ils ont attendu d'être sortie
d'harry la procédure il a prôné t il
elles apprennent était effondrée voulait
pas baiser devant les caméras non mais
bon jour pour 46% des femmes ce sont les
yeux d'un homme qui les font rêver vous
les yeux les mains et le coût et les
fesses non initiés non non il après nos
l'énervé pas le gentil
quand tu meurs
saint-louis bien heureusement alors 38
pour qu'ils ont déjà 38% des femmes on
regarde tous être comme tout le monde
38% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
le matin au réveil et 73% le soir au
coucher moi tout le temps moi ça me gêne
pas ah ouais on dit maintenant ok ah
ouais abbas effectue sa maman papa
programme est censé abordage n'importe
quand quand on n'y a pas d'heure n'y a
pas de moment mais oui tous dans la rue
le problème se cogner ouais ouais c'est
plus délicat voilà sa crainte si on se
fait piquer ainsi on fait un 69
personnes à voir reconnaître
alors 56% des femmes préfèrent faire
l'amour dans le noir
pas moi en suit avec moi mais c'est beau
de voir les yeux de son parti les yeux
oui pour marquer mes marques et les yeux
c'est bien mais pas suffisant
alors qu'un pour cent des femmes
refusent de se faire attacher vous moi
j'aimerais pas aujourd'hui les touches
no way salvepar au club elle est
rattachée août et il faut vous ferez
peut-être salut michel envie d'embaucher
dia merkel puis un moment ça fait et ma
femme est est toujours attaché très
élevé ok on cherche à être il veut pas
dire tout parce que j'ai des choses
comme le personnel là dedans mais elle a
un collier ou un collier de chien et je
ressors d'or il n'a jamais eu envie de
s'attacher
non pas encore mais là ils sont tout à
fait ça fait deux morts et de te
bâillonné dans les camps tandis que 13%
des femmes refusent de se faire attacher
serviable 59e voir ça comme ça ça te
rassure la robe en tulle ans la majorité
alors 65 % des femmes refusent des
relations à trois et vous moi je veux
pas 3g avec un wanna go contenant non 3
ça vous plaît pas non je peux pas croire
oui c'est rien j'ai planché rien 3 bâtir
15 20 25
indice 50 places quand on est parent ont
déjà rencontré damman idéal
la mode du moment et toujours la main
idéale à ses très beau ça faudrait leur
épargne à la musique
oh
là
[Musique]
julien lepers way we et les paroles la
musique music valait bien j'ai tout
aussi soudainement sur les plats les
paroles c'est bine bine de geek low
carbon et claude carlos barbas bah je
vais tenir au chan cette chanson c'est
la chanson du départ en vacances
tu sais quand on est dans la fuego avec
la fatigue et quant aux autoroutes du
sud on met cette chanson me relation car
une chanson qu sandri car bien 23% des
femmes pensent qu'un bon amant c'est
celui qui fait attention à ce que sa
partenaire atteignent l'orgasme pour
vous non s'il prend pas de plaisir lui
j'en prendrais pas d'accord c'est beau
bien l'enjeu c'est bon là je comprends à
la science à 71 % des gens seraient
choqués qu'un couple d'amis proches leur
propose d'aller dans free club
d'échangistes et vous bon ben je leur
dirai non mais ça reste mes amis ah
ouais
chacun fait ce que chacun fait ce qu'il
veut dans son lit d'accord d'accord je
passe à dans son lit et ses potes ont
parlé dans les clubs soient ses 1 6 %
des gens sont choqués par le
sadomasochisme et vous mais non il faut
ça vous choque pas mais ça me choque
avait pas très comme la moyenne la piana
66%
ça me choque moi ce qui me choque c'est
avec avec les animaux les enfants ces
animaux
on peut bien en q1
alors dernière question et non la
moindre cher leur delattre qu'est ce que
ça va être passera la lan wan 39% des
femmes refusent la fellation et vous les
39 % elle rate quelque chose en et
bouchons dans les ting
bien dans 69 % des couples la femme fait
le ménage chez vous dont 73 pour cent
des couples
la femme fait la cuisine chez vous oui
c'est pas très beau mais chez vous si
elle est célibataire
bah ouais je me fais la bouffe quoi
voilà par contre tu te fait pas le
ménage 50% des femmes fantasment sur
leurs partenaires du moment et vous pour
46% des femmes ce sont les yeux d'un
homme qui les font rêver et vous oui 38%
des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour le
matin au réveil
j'aime bien aussi et 73% au coucher
j'aime dire aussi
56% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
dans le noir et vous 49% des femmes
refusent de se faire attacher attaché 49
refuse 51 qui sont d'accord ouais ouais
et vous bougez pas pendant le jingle
alors vous avez vous refusé
c'est pour ça que je sois mariée je suis
certaine et des bricoleurs en fait
personne à porter très important non
mesdames après cette ce questionnaire
c'est sûr que là bas on va voir d imer
on va vous marier comme la roue selon
marie larusso ici 65% des femmes mariées
ah ouais non vous cherchez quoi chez toi
suis bien tout seul ça va bien je suis
pas toutes les filles que je rencontrais
veulent se marier moi et pourquoi je
suis pas demandeur
moi j'ai pas spécialement envie de me
marier à mon nom je suis une fille libre
indépendant tout va très bien pour
l'instant je suis bien et je n'ai pas
particulièrement envie d'être princesse
65% des femmes refusent des relations à
trois et vous mais qu'est ce que ça vous
regarde toi moi au moins je lui rende la
partouze
présenté en fonction des couples
seraient choqués qu'un autre couple leur
propose de faire l'amour à quatre et
vous non non ça me ferait rire oh faut
être deux pour que ça marche
j'ai une dernière question mais je n'ose
pas vous la poser honnêtement c'est pas
le style de l'émission
39% des femmes refusent la fellation et
vous je ne voulais pas vous la posez moi
et vous vous aimez bien on ne bouge pas
on ne touche pas on ne bouge pas pendant
ne bouge pas on ne bouge pas pendant les
guerres de bush pendant le génial oui
vous avez un petit peu bougé mais
c'était pas mal intentionnés ya le
bouchage mal intentionnés d'aprilia le
bouchage de quelqu'un qui se remonte les
jouets c'est accepter que j'aime pas
c'est le bouchage agressif à la bastille
bien alors vas-y 69 % des couples c'est
la femme qui fait le ménage chez vous
c'est plutôt lui il est bien de résident
mais c'est plutôt lui c'est bien dans 73
% des couples c'est la femme qui fait la
cuisine chez vous ainsi plus tôt c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt flou qui fait
d'accord faut dire à nos amis donc livré
50 50 et quand c'est la maison ce qui c
soit lui pour les steaks hachés soit
mort pour les tricks un fumiste en cas
d'accord
ces deux fois pas an les trucks est
d'accord je sais pas si tu as posé la
question celui qui descend les poubelles
on sait la 50% des femmes fantasment sur
leurs partenaires du momo et vous oh oui
puis sur d'autres gens c'est bien
46% des femmes ce sont les yeux d'un
homme qui les font rêver en premier non
moi ce sera plutôt la bouche et les mois
la bouche et des mains mais 40% vous
avez dit oui j'ai 10 46% des femmes donc
54 sentimentale aussi
ouais 73% des femmes préfèrent faire
l'amour le soir au coucher
non non pas du tout non non oui oui mais
bah non c'est à dire alors le matin au
réveil c'est vrai après le bain après le
bain le matin au réveil c'est sympa mais
il vaut mieux avoir une petite voix de
qui secoue la côte est mais bon c'est
quoi ce matin
j'aime le matin le matin à midi et soir
aussi bien peu dans l'après midi
d'accord il n'y a pas de problème si
elle ira faire l'amour avant de nous
dire adieu bien 49% des femmes refusent
de se faire attacher ça m'angoissait
vous avez peur qu'ils voulaient c'était
et qu'ils soient alors 65 % des femmes
refusent des relations à 3 vous aussi ça
vous intéresse pas non vous n'avez
jamais essayé
comment je les connais je suis content
je sais tu pas au québec si j'essaie
effectivement on vient de le voir une
fois de plus 54 % des femmes ont déjà
rencontré la main idéale
je crois aussi magistère j'espère pour
vous je viens de vous l'a alors à la la
la 71 % des couples seraient choqués
qu'un autre couple leur propose des
pratiques échangistes et vous j'aimerais
pas on va choquer ça me ferait rigoler
ouais d'accord et c'est ce qui est pire
que ça ça m'est déjà arrivé ah oui
d'un coup le groupe devient un peu un
assistant dans sa non avait pas du tout
non puis bon copain non plus je croyais
mais bon sa voisine est souvent tous les
deux alors mais c'est bien
66% des gens sont choqués par les
pratiques sado maso ça dépend ce qu'on
appelle ça dommage au classement car
c'est la routine pour le fouet c'est
pour le cheval n'a même pas pour même si
c'est votre jules alors même pas non
plus je n'ai pas besoin de le fouet
vous vous rendrez d'une balade à cheval
à la cravache qui traîne je rigole c'est
peut-être comme ça je vais te tuer
d'accord c'est sympa voilà j'en ai une
chose même pas vous la poser à l'essai
par les chants de la dore mais bon allez
je la pose d'ongles et 39% des femmes
refusent la fellation et non non non
c'est non maintenant c'est pas sympa
mais j'adore ça
il adore ça vous êtes d'accord moi
j'aime bien ça aussi abattre
dans 69 % des couples c'est la femme qui
fait le ménage
et chez vous commencé chez moi ouais
c'est moi tu poulmic sevriena karembeu
qui les fait le même
j'aime bien dans 73 % des couples c'est
la femme qui fait la cuisine est chez
vous oui c'est vrai on s'est vraiment du
plaisir
alors maintenant on va parler d'amour
38% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
au réveil 73% au coucher chez vous c'est
comment coucher coucher 73 % des couples
56% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
dans le noir et vous ou non par antoine
blin
jeudi la première place à l'ol a dit la
première fois dans le noir et après ça
une fois comment avoir la deuxième fois
tu as l'air de man bien voilà c'est
normal on apprend les gestes qui sauvent
le coucou qui est cassé
denis chocolat chaud raison mais on
continue attention à ça c'est très
important de cadres
oui j'écoute mon métier je finis les
dépassements télé docteur conviendra
grade guérit maintenant 34 % des femmes
acceptent que leurs hommes leur fasse
l'amour où il veut quand il veut
et vous non non tu vois là il faut pas
se laisser faire par des inconnus dans
un avion non je veux quitter si tu sais
pas elle avait déjà fait l'amour dans un
avion mais c'est super là ils sont
rencontrés dans un avion déjà situe dans
les mille ans ils sont contents alors 84
% des femmes sont satisfaites de leur
amant ou de leurs maris et vous ouais ça
va
savannah séduit cette huile arva
c'est arrivé c'est la tuile ce soir ça
c'est très intéressant aussi c'est des
vrais statistiques c'est des vrais
sondages vous dit c'est vous qui
s'intéresse beaucoup aux sondages kloet
33% des femmes disaient leurs
partenaires
ce qu'elle aimerait qu'il lui fasse
envie il faut dire voulu demander à
christian sinon ça va ça va vraiment
excellente
dames c'est évident pour lui c'est damon
si je me cache a justement je vous
demandais pas tant
oh la la il vous loi n'a bougé de
capable de demander un homme c'est dans
la relation n'avance pas j'ai patienté
toujours voir est d'accord je vais lui
réparer le cerveau
non
ça peut servir un jour là c'est très
important c'est super important
tous % des femmes sont d'accord pour
faire l'amour
le premier jour et vous adriana toujours
moi
je
je n'ai pas complètement
c'est un coup de fusil mais c'est
incroyable quand même y'a que 12% des
femmes qui sont d'accord pour faire
l'amour le premier soir et adriana est
dense et 12% bonne mais à l'échelle
madrid au nom bien attention 49% des
femmes refusent de se faire attacher ce
que dira contre 51% qui sont d'accord en
même temps mais bon est-ce que vous
faites partie de ses 49% qui refusent de
se faire attacher
ça me fait pas peur mais je comprends
j'ai du mal à continuer cette émission
pas loana oui j'étais d'accord pour
faire attacher pas trop d'accord mais
bon je peux quoi je comprends qu'on peut
aimer et excite excusez moi excusez moi
excusez moi lola excusez-moi l'ona vous
êtes tout seul
adriana et marié waylon différentes ça
oui elle est prête à faire plus de trucs
que vous et voilà alors 66% des femmes
sont choqués par le sadomasochisme et
vous je comprends mais ça vous gêne pas
nous n'irons pas plus loin vous savez
que c'est une émission était réputé pour
sa discrétion
alors voilà c'est une question plus
délicate suis désolé comment bon bah oui
39 je te regarde dans l'imposant excuses
que j'ai un peu non 30 39 % des femmes
c'est vrai oui refusé refuse la
fellation
et vous oui oui à lui dit à moi driano
tu te répondent absolument méritée elle
refuse à y
oui à l'axel alex 65% des femmes
refusent des relations à trois et vous
trois sets aussi qui est une jolie ville
vous refusez à 3 pour le moment 600
lycées
une question et si c'est à 3 vous prenez
un garçon ou une fille si vite en train
de gagner ses galons d'animateur du
service public
cissé à trois c'est plutôt un garçon non
j'ai la fuse complètement je dis plus
rien c'est pas grave parce que vous
savez le principe du joker si vous
répondez pas c'est que dallas qui
répondent sûrement c5 aucun claude alors
quoi après l'amour quoi
que se passe-t-il après l'amour pour 36
% des gens y slave 29 % des gens dorment
8% commence toujours pas fume fume
toujours pas boire ou manger 7% et ceux
qui recommence en c'est terrible eva que
6 %
vous êtes dans quelle catégorie web
plutôt rangée doit manger et vous claude
vous savez ce qu'on racontait comme
histoire dans ce genre dont on disait il
y en a qui boivent y en a et c
et il y en a cinq en ce qui concerne les
français il y en a 45 % qui rentrent
chez eux
m
ouais
merci philippe le physique d'un homme ne
séduit les françaises qu'à 4% mais pour
53 % des françaises c'est la
personnalité de l'homme qui les séduit
le plus
et vous moi aussi c'est la personnalité
à vous c'est physique
ah ouais s'il est la mieux tant mieux
mais sinon c'est pas le plus important
est votre avis de montréal il était il
avait il n'y a plus rien maintenant 38 %
des femmes préfèrent le matin au réveil
et 73% des femmes françaises préfèrent
le soir au coucher moi je préfère un
n'importe quand n'importe quand même en
pleine émission tu passes ton je voulais
tant par les belles tournures c'est
émission ça va être très bien cette
émission
voilà justement pour 34% des français
sait où il veut quand il veut
moi c'est pas de compte il veut c'est
quand je veux
elisa fiche 69 un tel succès
c'est vous qui me posait une question je
vous écoute l'interview vous avez fait
avec un proche ça m'a donné une petite
idée il ya une phrase du dalaï lama que
j'aime beaucoup qui dit oublie les
chèques mais n'oublie pas la leçon moi
la question que j'ai envie de vous poser
c'est quelle a été votre principal échec
dans votre vie et quelle leçon vous en
avez tiré
jamais jamais eu tellement d'échec
disons que je me suis fait virer de la
télé par exemple en 92-93 avec mon ami
laurent baffie ma faute 1 là donc c'est
un échec parce qu'après j'ai passé trois
en dehors et la leçon que j'en ai tiré
c'est qu'il fallait pas se prendre au
sérieux pas avoir la grosse tête pas se
prendre pour une star et que les gens
qui viennent ici le samedi soir ils
viennent pas pour moi parce que si la
semaine prochaine ya quelqu'un d'autre
ils viendront pour lui voilà c'est là le
sens du métier
alors 56% des femmes préfèrent faire
l'amour dans le noir
et vous moi aussi j'aime bien noir soit
quelque chose comme ça de très
mystérieux c'est donc imaginer des
choses alors 30 repas sont des femmes
disent toujours ou souvent à leurs
partenaires ce qu'elle souhaite qu'ils
lui fassent et vous moi je sais pas trop
alors mais qu'est ce que tu aimerais
bien qu on fasse locale s improvise pas
d'accord et celle improvise pas bien
mais je t'ai quand même il a une
deuxième chance à une deuxième chance
très bon tirage elisa 49% des femmes
refusent de se faire attacher et vous
j'ai jamais essayé mais ça doit être
je vais essayer c'est ça enfin il ya
attaché à attacher patient prend un
foulard de satin et fonda tâche un bras
au lit ça peut être un peu sensuelle
mais jean ligoté ses débuts tu sais le
début la ligoter béléné demande de
rançon
ah ouais d'accord 66% des femmes sont
choqués par les pratiques
sadomasochistes et vous je suis pas
choqué mais ça m'intéresse pas en tout
cas pas du tout non chacun fait ce qu'il
veut
privé c'est l'intimité je vous tends
choquer mais ça me tente pas moi je suis
plutôt quelqu'un qui aime la tendresse
et la sensuelle normal
alors j'aime pas trop qu'on me fasse mal
mais vous aimeriez faire mal non non je
ne supporte pas faire mal à quelqu'un
d'avoir mal non plus fouetter
calme-toi 39% des femmes c'est beaucoup
refusent la fellation et vous
non non je refuse pas
magnéto serge alors oui 65 ans et plus
avec 39 pour la fondation de ses 65 %
des femmes refusent des relations à
trois mois je refuse pas j'ai jamais
essayé gens j'en ressens pas le besoin
je suis très bien à deux quand j'étais à
2 71 % des gens seraient choqués qu'un
couple d'amis proches leur propose
d'aller dans un club échangiste et vous
je pense que je serai curieuse mais que
j'irais pas comme jc jamais allé non je
prends moi je suis jamais allé jamais
les où je suis curieuse de savoir
comment ça se passe et d'intentions j'ai
pas très envie d'y aller donc c'est très
bien parce qu'il va l'emporter si la
curiosité
après l'amour 36% des français se lavent
29% dorment 8% fume 7% boivent ou manche
6% recommencez pas beaucoup quand même
6% 5% regarde la télé et vous moi j'aime
bien
rêver regarder la personne avec qui je
veux faire l'amour on va rester là
dessus c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
m
j'avais à vous connaissez la maison oui
c'est toujours très convenable un
service public on a une mission
1 attention dans 69 % des couples c'est
la femme qui fait le ménage
et chez vous mais moi je suis tout seul
si beau si c'est pas moi qui fais part
ça ne le fait pas il habite pas moi ça
continue 73 % des couples
la femme fait la cuisine est chez vous
harry lui tout seul donc si je fais pas
vous faire pour le tgv donc des plats
froids mais je ne suis pas très loin qui
38% des femmes font l'amour au réveil et
73 au coucher des vous c'est enneigement
généreux trouve bien des jeunes viennent
depuis qu'elle a touché le magot
joliette
on essaye de savoir on est bien d'accord
si sylvie est en phase avec l'opinion
publique française pour une miss france
c'est la moindre des choses
56% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
dans le noir est bien bien 34% des
femmes font l'amour où il veut quand il
veut et vous non
tu peux t'amuser à lyon même s'il ya un
premier coup on n'aime pas les machos à
3% des femmes demandent à leurs
partenaires ce qu'elles veulent qu'ils
lui fassent et vous non
s'il improvise mal il est jeté voilà
prêt à dégager
ats
talisman cette classe là je vais pas
nuit on peut demander des forces bien
12% des femmes
beaucoup font l'amour lors de la
première rencontre
et vous bon c'est parce que j'arriverai
à la maison
49% des femmes refusent de se faire
attacher je suis partie de sa 49% la
ceinture me cela est trop bon la saturn
us comme ça je pensais pas compris je
dis pas attacher ligoté comme ça comme
un non mais j'ai caché vouloir en soi
oui non mais c'est pareil système de la
soumission j'aime pas 66% des femmes
sont choqués par des pratiques sado maso
c'est marrant ça et vous choqué non
parce que je pense qu'elle n'est degrés
si on est avec un foulard en soie ou le
suspense qu'est ce qu'elle va dire alors
et alors parce qu'elle veut dire moi je
sais que je voulais dire voulait dire
que c'est un petit peu un soir j'ai
zappé menottes
voilà c'est tout problème alors par
exemple regardez je me dis ah ben c'est
marrant ça 65 % des françaises refusent
des relations à 3 bah oui moi je vais
rebonds geneviève jamais jamais jamais
jamais à 3 jamais eu envie enfin du tout
c'est marrant ça marrant non
pareil pareil parce que
relation à trois gemmes pas partager et
puis si au bout de quelque temps de
relation commencée à trois ou dix ans
vous finissez à 15 pages pas vrai c'est
pas vrai parce que terminal 6 à 16 c'est
pas moi mais je veux dire si ses
partenaires a besoin de quelqu'un
d'autre pour pour s'éclater ben j'en ai
rien à faire là le garçon que j'ai pensé
parce qu il s'agit plus de partager dans
ce cas là il s'agit de doubler le
plaisir c'est quoi les idées non parce
que je suis bien non y'a besoin de
compter sur des journaux français n'a
jamais passé normal incroyable la
dernière question et non la mois après
l'amour 36 % des françaises se lavent
29% dorment 8% fume 7% boivent ou mange
6% recommence et 5%
regarde la télé je me lave
[Applaudissements]
or si vous êtres accord avec la majorité
des français
il était donc ça serait bien dans 69 %
des couples en france c'est la femme qui
fait le ménage
comment c'était chez vous ben en fait
c'est moi
les foyers la femme de ménage et de le
dire mais comme je suis souvent pas là
c'est pas lui
non c'est un petit côté macho ça aussi
si des fois ils aident des x y z
il est des îles et des oui oui je vais
pas aborder ce sujet mais là c'est vous
qui bat non mais bon je vais pas en
parler
ben faut que va reparler non c'est un
peu triste à thierry 73 % des couples
c'est la femme qui fait la cuisine est
chez vous comment c'était c'est moi qui
fais la cuisine
non mais non parce que j'aime ça j'aime
ça je voulais pas dire ça c'est du foot
et non c'est pas du foot et j'aime faire
et jenny le ménage et la cuisine j'aime
faire la cuisine
sonia 38% des femmes vous préfère faire
l'amour au réveil et 73 au coucher chez
vous c'était comment je suis pas contre
les 2 56% des femmes préfèrent faire
l'amour dans le noir
ben chez vous comment c'était chez moi
moi j'aime bien voir le regard quand
même pour 34% des femmes sait où il veut
quand il veut
ah non moi je suis peut-être pas je fais
pas partie de soirée 34 ans j'ai des
titres ainsi ont-ils lieu je dirais pas
non mais bon je vous ai remarqué oui
vous avez pas parlé non 33% des femmes
demandent à leurs partenaires ce
qu'elles veulent qu'ils lui fassent
beaucoup quand même 33 %
moi ça me gênerait demandé
ce sens il faut faire comprendre à la
personne en question la sociologie 1 12%
des femmes font l'amour lors de la
première rencontre
51 % des femmes sont d'accord pour se
rattacher vous attacher non ça ne
m'intéresse pas les objets les trucs 66%
les femmes sont choqués par les
pratiques sadomasochistes et vous avez
fait partie de ces femmes là alors je
trouve cela super bizarre oui je sais
pas qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais
moi ça me choque pas mais moi aussi
alors très bien qu'on ne connaisse pas à
65% des femmes refusent des relations à
trois et vous appareil à dos ça me
suffira de vous dire en couple ça suffit
très bien même une femme un homme une
femme oui la question je vous la pose
sont pas assez ou trop [ __ ] pose est
l'at il joue la pose alors est ce que je
veux pas je veux dire mon dieu
un voisin bon bah tu as bien enfin c'est
bien saisir ne pas la poser la question
qu'est la mer est pour moi plus personne
entendue toute façon c'est vrai nom
mehdi maladie rap non non non non non
non je te jure que je me sens bien j'ai
oublié mon cas ça j'ai pensé moi oui ou
non mais tu vas tu va en parler après
alors je suis ok chose dont je te jure
que j'en parle pas d'accord je te le
jure je le dis devant les caméras je
n'en parlerai pas alors tu peux mais a
répété
parce que du coup elle m'a tellement
choqué je sais qu'avec toutes les
accumule alors mais alors tu as promis
juré craché
je dirais je te demande si tu en fais
partie de ces 39% ou non non tu n'en
fait pas partie non
[Applaudissements]
38% des femmes préfèrent faire l'amour
au réveil et vous oui je me réveille
toujours avec un sourire et c'est
toujours dont 56% des femmes préfèrent
faire l'amour dans le noir et vous oh
non non je viens de là sa lumière
34% des femmes sont d'accord pour faire
l'amour où il veut quand il veut et vous
il ya un compromis le sait que ça se
discute entre deux personnes est ce
qu'on a envie de faire ça me connaît la
loi vous le faites tout ça oui avec des
photos de toi
sam 33% des femmes demandent à leurs
partenaires ce qu'elles veulent qu'il
leur fasse et vous la communication dans
la chambre à coucher est très important
si vous avez quelque chose il faut le
dire on peut pas imaginer que chaque
homme c'est ce que vous voulez et les
assassine un homme aime quelque chose eh
bien il faut qu'il me dise si moi j'ai
d'accord quelque chose je lui dis 49%
des femmes refusent de se faire attacher
vous ce soir
66% des femmes sont choqués par le
sadomasochisme et vous à like j'aime
bien la nourriture pas la punition quand
9% des femmes refusent la fellation et
vous j'adore la glace 65% des femmes
c'est beaucoup en france 1 refuse la
relation à trois et vous je ne dis
jamais jamais alors après l'amour en
france 36% des femmes se lavent 29%
dorment 8% fume 7% bois vous mange 5 %
regarde la télé et 6% recommence vous
êtes dans quelle catégorie
je recommence
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est une interview qui est basée
sur un sondage ifop
vous connaissez l'ifop c'est une société
autonome et c'est vrai 3 arrive il
faudra netanyahu ça veut dire un truc et
narbonne s'est passé ça veut dire
moustache on va voir donc si je pensais
comme la majorité des françaises 25% des
femmes considèrent christina que la
taille du sexe chez l'homme c'est
important oui oui oui
est-ce que vous vous sentez proche des
25 % ou des 75%
il ne s'est pas jetée 25% sont doutés
mais non tu plaisantes des graines à
l'aide pour le son et tous donc tour on
est toujours dans la course
non mais
samassa du lait
battu sur les bancs des bonds s'est
passé des trucs l'autre ils seront près
de 20 minutes faisant un concours de
[ __ ] tout de suite ça on va y arriver
donc voilà j'en ai eu une bon 38% et
fille cécile ifop 1 c'est tranquille
c'est pas moi 38% et filles pratiquent
la fellation
est ce que vous sentez proche des 38% ou
d autres voix tant que cela beaucoup 38
62% de shenyang c'est incroyable il a
répondu il a répondu à votre place
si 46% des femmes et ça c'est beaucoup
en revanche de la matière grasse 46
bourses 46% des femmes accepteraient de
faire l'amour en échange d'un cadeau
même si elles ont pas envie a à ses 10
soit pas envie du cadeau non de faire un
pauvre maintenant non mais c'est
incroyable
non mais ça doit te l'offrir est quoi
pour toi pour faire l'amour j'offre une
audi tt
on aurait tiré la monnaie ou payer mais
toutes options à 8 août alors christina
et je peux que les proches de la
majorité du 46%
non absolument pas même pas pour un
énorme cadeau
mais en dépit de tout cela d'helmand
voilà ça parce que moi j'ai fait de
l'italien à l'école avec rage et alors
est ce que la télé la jat où l'on
rendait le monde donc pour tout l'or du
monde
tu crois que j'ai une ouverture
l'attaqué je viens veulent m'aider alors
christine à 8 % des filles de 25 à 34
ans alors là vous êtes complètement dans
la cible un rêve de faire l'amour avec
une autre femme
qu'est ce que je suis clac
[Musique]
attention j'ai dit c'est que me pour
100% et dans les 90 et 92 % absolument
vous êtes vous êtes proche de la lawe
êtes une vraie française la douce pour
cent des femmes de moins de 35 ans sont
tentés par une expérience sado maso non
je ne suis pas tenté par ça mais je suis
embarrassé aimerait l'être mais je
discute pas mais ça va venir avec
l'ajustement
91 pour son défi de 18 à 24 ans
considèrent la fidélité comme une valeur
tout à fait actuel pour moi la fédé les
casser
oui je suis d'accord avec ce pourcentage
de femmes c'est une valeur absolue la
fidélité qui font qu'on peut avoir ou
pas avoir comme valeur mais c'est une
valeur qui n'a pas d'époque pour moi ça
a toujours existé c'est beau et bien
cette petite je vais tourner en rond de
au milieu
une splendeur c'est moi qui ai décrites
d'ailleurs festival
rocco appelle moi c'est le single
extrait d'un album qui sort en septembre
analystes et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus